زعنفة مثبتة ثلاثية الأبعاد بعض
أنابيب السباكة الكثير من الغراء
والقنبلة جاهزة ،
ثم إنها نظارات للرؤية الليلية تطفئ الأنوار
وتجذبني إلى الخط الأمامي
لوحدة طائرات بدون طيار النخبة في خدمة الأمن الأوكرانية ،
وشرطة الدوريات وشرطة باترول
تتطلع إلى إخراجها  موقعًا رئيسيًا روسيًا
مضادًا للدبابات مع ضربة دقيقة
وجدنا هذا الهدف مؤخرًا فقط
قال قائد الفريق أنه تم اكتشافه
حرفيًا اليوم وسيتم
تدميره اليوم لذا سنذهب إلى موقع إطلاق الطائرة بدون طيار
في الوقت الحالي من الواضح أنه
خطير للغاية ونحن  يجب أن يحذروا من
أن الروس لا يروننا
ضروريًا للطائرة بدون طيار كوادروكوبتر على
المنشطات قادرة على حمل حمولة ضخمة
تصل إلى 45 رطلاً في هذه الحالة
قذيفة هاون يقول الأوكرانيون إنهم حصلوا عليها من
انسحاب القوات الروسية في مكان آخر
ويستخدمون الآن  ضرب جيش بوتين الآن ،
ننتهي من التحضير ، القنبلة جاهزة
ونحن على استعداد للذهاب على ما يرام ،
إنها كبيرة بصوت عالٍ وهي تتجه
مباشرة إلى الموقف الروسي الذي
نحتاج إلى الاختباء هنا ، حيث
يصبح الصيادون سريعًا مطاردًا ، لذلك بالنسبة
للروس ،  تعتبر أطقم الطائرات بدون طيار أيضًا
هدفًا ذا قيمة عالية ، لذا من الواضح أن الروس
لا يريدون أكثر من قتل هؤلاء
الرجال
غير المنزعجين من القصف من حولنا ،
يطير الطيار مباشرة إلى الهدف
ويطلق القنبلة
في هذه اللحظة التي نطلبها من أوكرانيا
بحب ، لذا فقد أسقطت للتو  قنبلة نعم ،
هذا ما يبدو عليه الانفجار من
كاميرا الطائرات بدون طيار سوداء اللون ، الضربة
مؤتمتة بالكامل ، لن
تثبت رحلة استطلاعية أنها
أصابت الهدف ودمرته إلا في ساعات النهار ، وليس من
الواضح عدد القتلى والجرحى من الروس
هنا
سيسمح لقوات الدفاع الأوكرانية
بالمضي قدمًا ومواصلة الهجوم
الذي يقول إن الحد الأدنى من الخسائر سيؤدي إلى
خسائر قصوى للعدو من أجل
انتصار أوكرانيا ،
لكن الأمر لم ينته نظرًا لأن الطائرات بدون طيار تحلق مرة أخرى ، حيث
تظهر الرسائل النصية التي تم اعتراضها أن
الروس قد سمعوا الطائرة بدون طيار  وهم
يستهدفون
طيور العدو رصدت نصًا روسيًا
يفهم نصًا روسيًا آخر أجاب أنهم
يطلقون مشاعل لاكتشاف الطائرة بدون طيار الآن
يمكنك أن ترى
أوه نعم مرة أخرى ، هل
يطلقون النار علينا لمشاهدة الطائرة
أو لماذا لأنهم لا يستطيعون رؤية الطائرة
ولكنهم يطلقون النار على الصوت
[موسيقى]
أخيرًا ، تمكنت الطائرة بدون طيار من إعادتها مرة أخرى إلى
الحاجة للخروج من هنا بسرعة ،
هل يمكننا متابعتك ، دعنا نذهب لمتابعة
ما يقولون إنها مهمة ناجحة ،
يغادرها محاربو الطائرة بدون طيار تمامًا بالطريقة التي
أتوا بها من توصيل شبكة سي إن إن في
جنوب شرق أوكرانيا